في ملف تجارب الصاروخيه الكوريه الشماليه
اعلن الجيش الكوري الجنوبي ووزاره الدفاع
اليابانيه انبيونغ اطلقت صاروخا بالستين
اليوم
عددا من الصواريخ في وقت سابق من هذا
الشهر وقال سيئه الاركان المشتركه للجيش
في سول لان كوريا الشماليه اطلقت صاروخا
باليستيا غير محددا باتجاه البحر الشرقي
المعروف ايضا باسم بحر اليابان تذهب الى
تركيا
كيف تنظر اليابان الى استمراريه في عمليه
اطلاق الصواريخ اخرها اليوم
بالفعل بالنسبه لصاروخ اليوم قامت هيئه
الاركان المشتركه التابعه للجيش السوري
الجنوبي الاعلان عن هذا الصاروخ وانا في
وزاره الدفاع بانه قد تم سقوطه خارج
المنطقه الاقتصاديه الخامسه لليابان مع
عدم وجود اي اضرار لحقت بالسفن حسب خبر
التوحل من المتوقع ان تواصل كوريا
الشماليه قيامها بهذه التجارب الصاروخيه
مع وجود مناورات عسكريه تضم بلدان مختلفه
منها استراليا والهند خلال الشهر الحالي
وخصوصا مع وجود القوات الامريكيه وتعاونها
الثنائي ايضا مع كوريا الجنوبيه
هذه التجارب وزياده عدوان الكوريا
بان صاروخ اليوم هو احدث صاروخ في عامل
قياسيه لتجارب الصراخيه التي تقوم بها
كوريا الشماليه في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
بما في ذلك الصواريخ البالستيه العابره
للقارات التي اطلقتها خلال الاسبوع الماضي
وهناك مخاوف الان من ان كل قد تكون مستعده
بالفعل الى
قيامها بتجربه صاروخيه نوويه
لاول مره منذ عام 2017
شكرا لك من طوكيو مراسلتنا مع محمد سموره